right well the black mambas it's just
one anti-poaching initiative which has
been launched in South Africa over the
past few years to combat rhino poaching
Patrick Jordan is the founder of rhino
revolution he's in hood spray near the
Kruger National Park thank you so much
for joining us now the drop in figures
there were 100 1175 cases in 2015
compared to the record number of 1215 in
the previous year I have read that some
conservationists are the a bit skeptic
about those figures what do you make of
them it's a very minor drop in numbers
it is something to be thankful for that
at least hasn't increased year-on-year
and but yeah they are some cases that
are not reported and and some carcasses
that are found months after poaching
because the well they're difficult to
find sometimes in the bush which you
could cause a skewer numbers but as I
said it's it's a good thing that the
numbers are starting to level out at
least okay now let's talk about rhino
revolution how successful has your group
bean and what exactly do they do run a
revolution is a funding organization we
look for funding for various
anti-poaching initiatives such as the
black numbers were a pro track anti
poaching unit out of which we have
funded in the past and continue to look
for funding for we've also recently
started a rhino revolution
rehabilitation center where we currently
have for rhino cards and to vet nurses
that look after them and raised them
with the hope of releasing those cars
into the wild when they're ready so but
if why is it that private individuals
are having to form these anti poaching
units is it that the government isn't
doing enough the government is I guess
doing what it can in the national parks
the private sector doesn't get
government funding so yes we've turned
to many private organizations like rhino
revolution and and others that focus
funding for the private sector to fund
things like the black numbers and as I
said other other anti poaching
initiatives so do you take heart when
you hear that the number of rhinos
poached has dropped I mean you do in
South Africa have eighty percent of the
world's rhino population and there are
fears that they could be extinct within
ten years but with this news of this
drop in figures do you do you take heart
do you see some light at the end of the
tunnel yes as I said it is heartening to
hear that that at least the numbers are
leveling out that that doesn't mean that
we can relax them and the numbers
haven't decreased significantly to that
the deaths are less and births so the
rhino population is still going to be
decreasing and so yes it does I do take
heart in it but no that doesn't mean we
have we can stop doing what we're doing
it means we need to keep doing what
we're doing an increase what we're doing
the idea here is to have zero rhino
poached okay Patrick Jordan the founder
of rhino revolution thank you so much